let's sideway to censorship because uh I
have this I have a story from law fair
Supreme Court grants certiorari I'm
pronouncing that wrong probably and
Gonzalez V Google and Twitter V tomne an
overview
I'm not sure these are the exact case I
believe these are the cases in question
but I highlight these stories to tell
you that uh I had a phone call with
Google today
it was scheduled in advance a few weeks
ago I received an email where it was
sent I I believe to larger YouTube
channels warning that section 230
this is The Shield big Tech uses to
eliminate content they they don't like
as distasteful while being immune from
any responsibility due to hosting some
of this content I believe they're on
track to lose these Protections in a
very serious way so Google started doing
this reach out got an email can we focus
on that point because I think it's a big
one in terms of the odds that they're
going to lose I think the odds are very
high they're going to lose because their
argument is we're we're not an editorial
world just a publisher meaning anyone
could put anything out there our hands
are clean however if I'm editorial if
I'm picking articles I'm promoting
people then I am having a voice and
therefore the protections don't apply to
me then I can be guilty of libel or
whatever slander whatever it is and very
clearly all of these uh Instagram
Facebook uh Twitter and YouTube are
putting their finger on the scale and
promoting some things over the other
right I make editorial decisions it's
unambiguous so uh they're panicking yeah
I got an email and it said we want to
make you aware about a supreme court
take taking on these cases which will
have a big impact on recommendations if
the Supreme Court rules against us or
our position we may not be able to
recommend your content anymore and you
know what I thought when I saw that Ian
should do porn
but maybe if
um that's a good one but no I left are
are you kidding me that they would email
this when we know for a fact they
suppress our content and I say we know
for a fact because let me let me let me
tell you this I get a phone call from
the guy we had a meeting I get the email
it says please schedule here's my
availability I don't want to be mean to
the guy he called me and he was
advocating for his position I respect
that he wants to talk to me again
tomorrow
I scheduled the meeting for whatever
date was available and uh we had some
emergency stuff going on today obviously
we had a heck of a yesterday so you know
of course we get slammed with a bunch of
stuff today you get it but I get a phone
call I'm in the car and I'm like well I
answered anyway and I'm like hey I'm in
the car and I'm like FaceTiming this
dude and he basically was was explaining
that if the Supreme Court
agrees with these people
that means YouTube look section 230 says
you can't sue I'll I'll give a
simplified version
can't sue YouTube because of what Temple
says I am putting something out there
YouTube did not say it however it also
says YouTube can't be considered a
publisher or of his content even if they
moderate and have editorial control over
the platform now how do you have it both
ways yeah separation you always have it
both ways right so uh so they call me
and they say listen
it may be and this is so hilarious the
guy's like look we we might not be able
to issue recommendations anymore that
means search because we use an algorithm
so if someone imagine someone searched
for your name and the and the videos
wouldn't come up
and I'm just sitting there like oh you
imagine it huh imagine it huh I went off
I'm sorry I snapped I said we we hit 800
000 views on our video no trending no
recommendations there was a period where
Google
removed this YouTube channel from all of
their search you could type in the title
of a video and I was like and you're
gonna call me and tell me that I should
be worried about this you understand
that you have so much weight against me
we succeed in spite of what you've done
that if YouTube strips you of your
powers we'll actually benefit from it
yeah two points first people at home
don't realize that when Tim gets this
angry his beanie becomes a mushroom
cloud so it's kind of really cool to
watch and I'm the victim of this too on
Instagram you can't search for my name
you can't even tag me you have to spell
out Michael malice because I'm
completely Saturday on Instagram if you
try to follow me it gives you a warning
telling you not to follow me because I'm
I spread quote misinformation you try to
tag me it says don't you sure you want
to tag this guy misinformation you're
bad you're badass YouTube has been
screwed me for for in my entire career
what you described Tim has been
happening throughout my entire career
YouTube promotes authoritative sources
CNN MSNBC fake news spreaders they don't
spread Independence
and it's almost impossible to find
Eden's pornos I have a look a lot look
on the Cross Match I want to tell you
more about what this guy was saying I'm
not actually porn on there he said
something to the effect of imagine if we
could no longer recommend you and you
are no longer part of like I'm
paraphrasing something like the the
mainstream conversation or something and
I'm just like guy that's what you've
already done we created a new Channel
timcast music we put up a video on it it
gets half a million views in a day two
days later it is trending number 23 our
number I think number 23 on YouTube
surprise surprise a brand new Channel
with a big video gets play We're
trending but IRL can get half a million
views on an episode in two hours and
never reach that Mark can I make a point
my understanding is from someone who has
inside knowledge about this that the
trending section on YouTube is manual
right of course so so it's not organic I
think it's a mix but I think it's
largely editorial yeah I think there's
obviously a component but my you know my
point was to the guy said why is it that
we know for a fact you can't Google
search my videos
like Facebook comes up you can't even
you can't even search my channel when
you would search for Tim cast or Tim
cast IRL it would it would just show you
playlists created by other people
because they removed us from search and
you're telling me that you want the
ability to be free from all liability
when you choose to promote political
speech from say Isis but then you expect
me to defend you when you put the
weights on us when we call out these bad
players I hope I said this to him I hope
that that the Supreme Court rules
against you and everything is forced to
return to reverse chronological feed
because I will do better from it uh
absolutely but this talks to earlier
about how the suits are often oblivious
because I bet you any money that he had
the exact same speech for everyone who's
trying to call he had a list of like 50
people and he had the exact same speech
as to who he's talking to and then the
call got disconnected I guess he he that
was us we control the phones and we
didn't like that
um maybe he got disconnected but uh as I
was talking and I'm I'm heated but I was
being played out like a nine nights not
you personally but dude don't call me
and think I'm gonna side with you on
this one I don't think he did his
research I just love the idea that like
you're gonna holler up like katanji
brown Jackson and be like come on and
she's like all right like I've got to
rule and pay for them no no right but
but I also thought that it was kind of
funny that Google thinks they can start
calling creators and saying support our
artists they can I bet you a lot of
these creators are completely Arc
synthetic and a function of their
algorithm but I'm also willing to bet
that when he calls leftists they said
this same thing I did LGBT creators have
been complaining a long time that
YouTube suppresses that because it's not
Advertiser friendly so they're going to
call them and be like defend our
immunity they're gonna say no restore
reverse chronological feed so that we
can have my my video can be shown to my
followers I bet you there's a lot of
people who are happy to play ball
because if you look at any industry the
people that top are often happy to lick
the boot there's there's always some
Ralphs willing to suck up to power and
authority but I think a lot of people
are absolutely frustrated and pissed off
at these algorithms controlling our
society that have been absolutely a net
negative not just to the mental health
of this country but when we see the the
mental Warfare that that's being created
out there what are you you're going to
be doing something here what do you mean
by algorithms say it name them well like
like I'm not going to you know bat an
eye when the same huge organization that
labeled me a conspiracy theorist now
won't be able to editorialize I'm not
going to be mad at that it's it's
totally fine let people see what they
want to see it's that simple if they
subscribe to something if they want to
see something let them see it where
adults here stop treating us like
children I don't want to be recommended
these stupid RV videos or these stupid
truck life videos I don't want to be
recommended some kind of psyop stop with
the psyopsis stop with the nonsense I
want to listen to what I want to listen
to and that's what the people demand and
that's what the people will get I'm on
Twitter and they have their algorithmic
feed and their their home feed that's
what it's called and they have the
reverse chronological feed
I do really well posting my content and
getting shares and getting followers
without any kind of weird algorithmic
impedance so YouTube deserves to have
that stripped away from them I my
Twitter following went up uh in by an
order of quadruple new followers a day
when some switch got switched 10 days
ago and Ben askren who is now oh for
three uh my Show episode with him is
dropping next week when we recorded he
had more followers than me and was
rubbing at my face and now I have 10 000
more than him so suck at askren I now I
know what Jake Paul feels point being
there was clearly some kind of
algorithmic screwry on the back end that
was hurting me before and he's either
neutral or helping me now yeah I got I
experienced the same thing probably you
too Tim have you heard there's like that
internet meme law that says any online
Forum uh without moderation will become
right uh something like that any any
online Forum without sufficient
moderation will become right wing oh
okay yeah I think it's more like it'll
become radicalized
Conquest Laws of Power the second one is
any organization not dedicated to being
right wing will become left-wing so that
might be an inversion of that really
yeah I guess that that's the assumption
that the the powers that be right now
have been co-opted by some sort of
leftist mentality right sort of
communist or socialist uh move well but
uh I you know so I don't know where that
Meme came from but you take a look at
like Reddit
pre-sciop control by uh you know big
powerful packs and organizations yeah
the memes were all like well that's
that's where the McDonald's came from
right exactly and and uh I think it was
MIT technology review said that the
Donald and 4chans Politically Incorrect
were the progenitors of almost all of
the memes that were going viral they
were funny people liked them the Pepes
they'd end up on Twitter and then Katy
Perry was sharing them no moderation it
was just meritocratic the best memes
Rose to the top everyone liked it shared
it that culture built and then all of a
sudden they had what leads to I guess
the dead internet Theory this emergency
Panic session where moderation comes in
like crazy
there's uh Michael Tracy tweeted this
Twitter's rules from 2015. pre this big
emergency meeting was basically don't
incite violence but we will not
intervene in any disputes between people
now it's we take a political stance
hardcore Etc yeah YouTube in 2006 when I
started June 2006 on the cross Mac
Channel go check it out it's uh it was
all owned by YouTube Google had not
bought the company yet that was like a
year and a half later and they were just
featuring whatever they wanted every day
there'd be 10 featured videos every day
and throughout the day they dropped down
one every like two hours you know a new
one would come up so you'd be slowly
siphon off the front page it was all
idealistically motivated whoever was
controlling YouTube at that time was
deciding it was Steve Grove who was
running politics was like I like your
video Ian I'm gonna feature it in news
and politics so he liked it there his
political are both our political agenda
got pushed which was real Barack Obama
but then at some point Google bought the
company I saw that's dangerous that's
corporate conglomeration this could be
really bad people started getting banned
and uh then the politics people knew
people probably came into the power of
the in control so since the beginning
it's been a platform and a public like
they are platform they are deciding who
gets to be seen since the very beginning
I think Elon Musk has shown us a lot of
what this is big advertisers are scared
because left-wing activists organize and
they they organize predominantly on
Twitter these campaigns against them now
there's uncertainty and they don't know
what to do I think it's funny
advertisers announced that they were
going to pull off their ads or reduce
spending on Twitter due to uncertainty
and my personal view is the uncertainty
likely is which side is going to attack
us more and we don't know who to side
with anymore same thing this is how uh
Times Square for Pride became all
rainbows you know 25 8. I I've tweeted
this before that only Corporate America
can make sodomy perversion seem
downright boring uh but before gay
marriage became universally accepted in
corporate culture they just kept their
mouth shut like they would have these
little organizations days like oh you
know we have this little program but now
you buy a candy bar and it's you know
it's a rainbow it's got a rainbow flag
on it and talking about the Skittles
except except for their their brands
that operate in like the Middle East or
right those the ones that never don't
they have a banned substance and
Skittles that was recently found out
that was absolutely really horrible hold
on I don't think that's that's where
there's I don't think that's where they
hide the arena currently do you think
that we should Advocate to ban advert
corporate advertisement in social media
no
what really is that such a First
Amendment are you communist yeah go back
Michael keeps looking at me when Ian
says stuff with this look of like I
can't believe he's social media is I
love him and I'm in love with him it's
working I love you too Michael you know
he said something and you look at me
it's super serious yeah because I think
the huge social media networks I mean
the ones I think where their code should
be freed like they're working in the
Commons and at some point if the
advertisers are controlling the commons
by by blackmail or by saying we will
take our money away if you don't do what
we say that's the bad for the commons I
I don't disagree with that but what I'm
saying is this is something that you're
trying to kind of square a circle and
there's no easy answer one way or
another if you're gonna have a
subscription model then it's gonna be
kind of Karen oriented because the ones
who complain the most are going to have
disproportionate amounts of power so
things are going to be kind of
inoffensive so I don't see an easy
answer here right because if you remove
advertisers from YouTube for instance
all these people with the partner
program are I don't think it's called
the partner program anymore it's
something else but everybody would start
losing their ad Revenue that could
destroy tens of thousands of careers you
know thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time